i'm sitting here thinking trump's gonna
milk it for all it's worth
he's gonna figure out what his legal
options are he's gonna go to war i can't
imagine him giving up
but now i'm kind of like is is trump
gonna push it for a law fair victory
where he can jam up several states so
there's no certification and then try
and win or is that just so far-fetched
however i'm like think about what year
it is you know
mass pandemic lockdown riots sweeping
the country
peaking in in june all this weird crazy
stuff happening and everyone's saying
it's 2020 and i'm like doesn't really
mean anything it's like superstitious
but friday the 13th is coming up oh is
it
well that changes everything it changes
everything everything forget everything
i said in this conversation
i'll bet he's got i think he's gonna
push it man i think he's going in the
distance because the amount of secret
votes
so basically how many votes got counted
in secret of the four
well they're claiming 450 000 were
counted without meaningful access and
this is just in one place
but hold on there's also a sworn
affidavit that ballots were coming in in
the middle of the night
we have a we have a georgia gop guy who
said
in the at like 4 a.m they said we're not
counting anymore so everyone needs to
leave
and then once they left they started
counting again so there's there's
a bunch of these claims and this is on
top of computer programs
testimony florida testimony
congressional testimony of a guy saying
he built a program that flips a vote
5149
um you can look it up on youtube that
was a long time ago yeah it was like
2001 or something this is like 20 year
old technology
yeah and then this comes out this air
force general
starts telling us about this program
called scorecard so who will hold this
computer
i don't know i don't i don't know about
it i know i don't know either but like
this is a big
deal before you say that we gotta who's
this guy he's a he's an air force
general
and i don't know his name offhand but he
was on uh steve bannon's war room
explaining the uh score the hammer
super computer and the scorecard
software
see i don't know anything about this i
don't know how to you know i i i
actually did listen to
a press conference yesterday from the
secretary of state or it was it was an
election administrative official who was
a republican in in georgia who
addressed rumors about whatever that is
that you're talking about
so i don't know the full details but he
said it was a a hoax and this is a
republican
and i don't know maybe he's not
he's correct or he's in on it or he's
like he's
a deep state act operator i don't know
but
um i would have to you know look for a
little bit further into what you're just
talking about isn't it isn't it weird
though that they like published a poll
from reuters
it says nearly 80 percent of americans
say biden won
white house ignoring trump's refusal to
concede
i'm like when did we ever need a poll to
tell people americans think joe biden
won
it's so much manipulation right now this
is i don't know
multi levels of manipulation too i agree
i think that is interesting you know i
mentioned before we started
i'm curious now if in 2000 there were
polls run
in this like interregnum period before
which was declared winner about just
asking people who they think won the
election as opposed to like who they
favor just who do you think won
because then it wouldn't be totally
unprecedented but i mean it is i mean
the
the impetus for polling like that is
that trump hasn't continued the election
so right i mean it makes some sense why
they would run those polls but
it is sort of curious yes
a little bit weird a little bit i'm
saying but like but it's 20 20 so i'm
not surprised
if they if if the results came in they
said we're calling it for biden and then
they just
shut up like i would be like yeah that's
it i got this guy's name lieutenant
general thomas
mckierney how do you spell it uh thomas
mick m-c-i-n-e-r-n-e-y
lieutenant general of the air force i
believe i can't spell that what did you
say yeah
m-c-i-n-e oh mccarran
yeah he's big time 83 years old this is
the guy
yeah former uh air force fighter pilot
retired vietnam war
oh wow so this guy went on bannon's show
and claimed that they were
they had the ability to manipulate
elections basically they've been using
this software's uh
spying tool against like terrorist
organizations and now they've turned it
apparently according to him they've
turned it on
people to use it voter fraud i'll tell
you there's a uh
media matters is calling hammer the new
conspiracy theory see this is the thing
i
don't i don't care for this stuff you
know why we don't need it it is a
conspiracy it's just
when we inspired was it the american
government against isis and now
no no no no who cares we don't need
these accusations or stories
it doesn't have anything to do and it's
a distraction it's calling that this
entire thing into question for me
and it creates a cr it creates a
discussion where regular people say
you're insane and i don't want to hear
anything well i think the real
discussion is that paper ballots are
malfuncted and that we need to go online
under a blockchain
or some sort of immutable database
absolutely otherwise you're going to be
counting votes in back rooms for ages to
come and you're going to be relying on
people's trust
paper ballots are what provide some
degree of security in the
authenticity of elections i would think
not you know if it goes 100
i mean that that was the move after 2016
and
kind of shed light on some of the
democratic inconsistency because people
when they were hearing all these
allegations from democrats that oh
russia must have hacked wisconsin or
something
they're saying okay if you want a
legislative fix to that let's institute
nationwide paper ballots that we can go
and verify after the election
and nothing happened on it you have hard
documents if we go digital
someone could just draft a bunch of fake
bouts and there's nothing to look at
everything is you don't have the hard
ballots
wait you don't know who does no you
don't we don't
so i saw i saw them in a warehouse
in georgia they do have them yeah
the required statutorily to keep them
for who's they
and where do they keep them and how do
you know what they're doing just because
you don't know doesn't mean there's a
conspiracy and i'm not allowed to know
no that's not true you could walk in and
you could talk to
the county election official who will
explain it to you and you have to rely
on him telling you the truth
sure but you can stand there while they
bring the belts in watch them pull the
ballot out look at the ballot watch them
open and see who was
voted for you can watch all that the
problem is donald trump's lawsuit is
stating they blocked that
that's the issue so that's one level of
an issue in that capacity you are
correct
so trump is creating a legal challenge
to 450 000 ballots because
they blocked meaningful access like they
were they were actually supposed to
this hammer scorecard thing is another
level completely i'm talking no no we
don't we don't this
thing is good when you come out to
regular people and say there's a top
secret military program called
hammer score well there's prism i mean
edward snowden dropped
of course and i'm saying when you go to
regular people you say that they tell
you you're
insane it is no one's told me i'm insane
dude
i'm just quoting an air force general
you you you live in a world where
regular working-class people don't
and if you go knock on someone's door
right now and say they stole the
election with hammer i'm not forcing it
down so much i'm just bringing it up man
and they're going to be like this guy's
crazy
well you're allowed to say that dude and
yes i advise you do you want
do you want to challenge do you want a
legal challenge do you want to make sure
that i think it's just
so so what you need is a sound legal
argument
that is in right with within the right
stuff this stuff's conspiracy there's no
proving any of it that's the problem
exactly just insanity so what we can see
is there's anomalies
like did you see that uh some of the
jurisdictions violated benford's law of
numbers
that i don't know so benford's a lot of
numbers just just to respond to you
really quickly though before i
forget is i think you're right on some
level and i'm not even sure that if you
did not go
knock on the door of some regular
working-class person who's not
overly attuned to politics that they
wouldn't be receptive
to some argument okay what a yeah who
said this you know because a lot of
people don't have a lot of instinctive
faith
in our institutions right including the
media including the government so like i
don't know that that would be too much
of a stretch in order to convince
somebody up but the point is
you have to prov if you want to actually
establish what it is that you're
positing beyond just
vague assumptions about the corruption
of stuff
you have to go a little further than a
you know there was something said in
2001 about some program you know like
there's there should be evidence that's
attainable that would
substantiate what you're what you're
saying i would love it if there was if
we could somehow get our hands on the
cia
but then then again like why wouldn't
this have been the case in 2016.
for all we know it was i mean it's crazy
so that they said they just so they put
trump in and then they
took him out we actually were going
crazy with conspiracies earlier just
kind of having fun and that was one of
them yeah well
well but this was just so yeah and then
like the harp is going to make volcanoes
explode
that was you that was me we were saying
a whole lot of like what ifs like what
if like the russians really did hack it
so but we were being silly but uh what
if trump was like the ultimate deep
state agent
all along hold on hold on this is a real
conspiracy theory uh it started
during the election that hillary clinton
and trump were actually friends
which they were at one time and and i
have a photo from frank
lori attended his wedding and everything
i was at fort lauderdale and they were
protesters outside of a trump rally
holding a picture of the clintons and
when trump together
and they were saying they're friends
they're in on it it's a it's all rigged
and the and that's why hillary clinton
didn't challenge the election she went
uh i wasn't supposed to lose
because that was the intent i'm not
saying it's true i'm saying i think if
it weren't remotely possible for
hillary clinton to have ascended to the
presidency she would have pursued that
right i don't care how friendly they
were if she attended his wedding in
mar-a-lago
so so so back to benford's law it's
something that people keep bringing up
over and over again
i'm not a mathematician i can't tell you
if this is true this is one of the
things that we're seeing pop up on the
internet
and benford's law is that uh if you were
to go throughout your day
writing down numbers you would see more
ones than twos
more twos than threes more threes than
four so quite literally you're watching
the street you see a mailbox
and then you're like i'm gonna write
down the mailbox it's sick four three
one seven
and you keep doing that then you
tabulate how many fours you found
you will have more threes than fours and
it creates a sliding scale
so a bunch of people are posting various
jurisdictions that voted where
biden's uh vote totals violate benford's
law
meaning there's wild numbers this is
important because we've actually
international auditors have used
benford's law as justification for
or probable cause of voter fraud and
that's why people are now bringing it up
the other thing i'll mention is i got a
tweet right here i said
bbc is going to have to retract this old
article titled quote
vote rigging how to spot the telltale
signs
because two of the things they they
point to that show voter fraud is a
delay in announcing results
we had and we still do a serious delay
with several states
and also voter turnout numbers that
exceed
99 or 98 or 99 they go on to mention in
this article from the bbc from 2016 when
they're auditing elections in say africa
the reason why getting voter turnout
above 90 or 95 percent
is typically impossible is because
people move and people die
thus in places like australia where you
can vote by mail and online and it's
compulsory
they still only get around 90 to 95
voter turnout yet i have a tweet
ucf tweeted since 2017 our campus has
been recognized as a voter-friendly
canvas campus
today ucf's voting precinct precinct 538
topped the 100 voter turnout in the 2020
election at 107.56 percent
my response was the bbc is going to have
to retract this article because
certainly that's not fraud or or
impropriety in our country well what's
so hilarious is that
and this is sort of tangentially related
but in
october or november of last year there
was a
presidential election in bolivia and evo
morales ended up being ousted in a coup
because we were told there were too many
election irregularities
for it to have been legitimate and a lot
of it stemmed from the fact that rural
precincts which were more pro-morales
the votes were tabulated later on
because it took a while due to the
infrastructure right or whatever
but really it didn't take that long
compared to the united states again
we're
still sitting around here a week later
we don't have
calls in georgia what's going on in
alaska arizona or even yeah last year
like they're like carrying the bag of
belts like from barrow alaska to
anchorage
even i checked as of last night if you
look at the
number of precincts reporting in a
number of the vote reporting
in like manhattan or queens or
westchester it's like 50 or 60 percent
so if new york actually was critical in
terms of determining the outcome there
would be
even a bigger right uproar because
who knows what's happening there
administratively but you know we
the you know u.s never applies the same
standards that it uses
to berate and lecture other countries
which are supposedly less exceptional
than us
um as it applies to itself i mean
you know i thought this was wasn't this
a country that like imposed democracy on
iraq and afghanistan like you know we
still can't even add it again
yeah but but but we can't even like get
results from arizona a week later it's
so crazy that it's taken this long
there's never been anything even like a
tenth of this
bizarreness lengthwise well has there
has it ever stretched out more than two
days after the
the election day yes i mean yeah so in
florida
two thousand straight a month and a half
and a half no no not over 37 days
yeah 37 38 um well then and then they
never even like
i mean the supreme court intervened to
prevent them from finishing the
uh recount yeah in florida so that
wasn't even completed
right we've had we've had an election
where there was a tie
and a a a council was created
of democrats republicans lawyers and
judges who then decided the outcome of
the election
like totally outside of the constitution
when al franken was first elected to the
senate in minnesota in 2008
it was so close against norm coleman
that it wasn't decided until the
following
july if i'm not mistaken so july 09
wow so it can take forever especially
when the margins are so close but
you know this is the most powerful
country in world history we have so much
financial economic cultural social power
and we can't get together to have
efficient elections
in regards to florida and um uh the 2008
one is that
who would you say it was it took until
al franken's
al franken yeah were the votes tallied
the day of but then there was just
they had there was recounts they had to
do recounts so it's never been this case
where
the votes haven't even been tallied yet
a week later
i don't know i have to double check on
that i mean i think it did take
well hold on hold on think about this
way certification happens
on december uh uh i'm sorry electoral
college
certification is this is the 14th of
december well first first
states have to certify right and then
electors
are appointed and then they do then they
formally meet
uh at the electoral college in like
mid-december if that that's what it was
in 2016
okay um
deciding i'm trying to pull up the uh
the app like the actual
timeline of how the electronics good
because i'm seething
so anyway the point is back in the day
we didn't have the internet
you'd be like you'd walk to the the the
swimming hole where there's like you
know
billy jenkins back i got your ballot
right here son and you'd be like fill it
out and you'd give it to him and just
cross your fingers i guess
and then he puts on the post the guy
rides the horse to
the capitol and then you're just like
well i voted and then you just
that's it you never know what happened
today it takes like two weeks before
they'll even
tell you to confirm your vote but i mean
like the idea that we are getting
night the night result like we turn the
tv on and they're like here's the
president
that's unpr that's like we didn't have
that back then you know before tv and
radio okay 1800s
you'd be like i wonder who the president
is oh so they'd always be counting the
votes for
the votes would be coming in from oh
that probably that too
because they didn't have the transport
technology so it'd be like votes would
be coming in randomly over the
certain span of time but with the
internet you would think that we would
have gotten better at counting our votes
i think so well i mean florida for
example has gotten a lot better they
learned their lesson
they did i mean they actually instituted
legislative reforms after 2000 that
very much made their system more
efficient
and i think we're probably going to see
something like that in some of these
other states especially given this
conversion to
i hope i'm voting but i mean another
complication is that in florida they
were permitted to count their mail in
voting
before election day uh whereas in
or begin you know begin the counting so
they could announce so the winner would
be apparent on election night
but in pennsylvania they weren't
permitted to do that by state law thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you